digamos que tengo un frasco con un
líquido misterioso aquí y quiero
averiguar qué está sucediendo y el
primer paso es pensar esta es una sola
sustancia o es una mezcla de múltiples
sustancias y me voy a enfocar en este
vídeo en una técnica para separar las
sustancias para conocer al menos cuántas
hay y esta técnica generalmente se
conoce como cromatografía pero nos
centraremos en la cromatografía de capa
fina que es la más común que podemos
encontrar pero otras variaciones de la
cromatografía como la cromatografía en
papel operan con principios muy
similares entonces lo que vamos a hacer
es colocar encima de algo como vidrio o
plástico una capa delgada de una
sustancia polar sólida ahora lo que
normalmente se hace es poner una capa
fina de gel de sílice que es la
sustancia polar sólida más comúnmente
utilizada y que también es porosa el que
sea porosa es realmente importante
porque queremos que el líquido tenga
acción capilar y viaje a través de ella
ahora el gel de sílice como mencioné es
muy polar lo que vamos a hacer es tomar
parte
a sustancia misteriosa y vamos a colocar
un punto de esta en el gel de sílice
luego vamos a tomar esta placa que tiene
el gel de sílice y el pequeño punto de
nuestra sustancia misteriosa y vamos a
sumergir sólo un extremo de la placa en
una solución y es muy importante que la
solución sea menos polar que el gel de
sílice menos polar aquí y hablaremos un
poco sobre lo que sucede dependiendo de
qué tan polar sea esto ahora por lo
general esta será una cantidad muy
superficial de solución que como veremos
será una especie de solvente y
normalmente se pone en un recipiente
cerrado como éste para que este líquido
no se evapore y luego que crees que va a
pasar
bueno como mencioné esta es una
sustancia porosa por lo que habrá acción
capilar este fluido en la parte inferior
se moverá hacia arriba a través del gel
de sílice a través de los pequeños poros
del gel de sílice esta es la fase
estacionaria porque la llamamos así
bueno porque no se mueve y puedes
imaginar que llamaremos a este solvente
menos polar la fase móvil porque
viaja a través del gel de sílice recoge
parte de esta sustancia misteriosa y la
transporta y digamos que esta sustancia
misteriosa está compuesta de dos cosas
diferentes si una parte de la sustancia
es más polar significa que se sentirá
más atraída por la fase estacionaria que
es muy polar y entonces no avanzará
mucho mientras que la parte de nuestra
sustancia misteriosa que sea menos polar
no se sentirá tan atraída por el gel de
sílice por lo que viajará más lejos con
el solvente entonces tal vez podría ser
así y harás esto hasta que la fase móvil
llegue a la parte superior del gel de
sílice justo aquí y la razón por la que
a esto se le llama cromatografía es
porque cuando originalmente hicieron
esto en realidad estaban separando
varios tejidos en la vegetación que
tenían diferentes colores croma se
refiere a los distintos colores pero no
tiene que referirse necesariamente a
cosas que tienen colores diferentes a
veces es posible que necesites una luz
ultravioleta para verlos pero cuando
realizas la cromatografía de capa fina
verás que el punto original se habrá
desplazado varios grados
con el solvente y luego habrá múltiples
puntos dependiendo de cuántas cosas
había en tu mezcla original y como acabo
de mencionar esta cosa de aquí esta es
la cosa menos polar y va a viajar más
lejos que la cosa más polar la sustancia
constituyente más polar porque la cosa
más polar es más atractiva para el gel
de sílice que es estacionario y hay una
manera de cuantificar qué tan lejos
viajaron estas cosas con relación a tu
solvente y esto se llama factor de
retención cuya abreviatura es f
subíndice r y se define simplemente como
la distancia recorrida por el soluto
dividida entre la distancia recorrida
por el solvente y debemos ser claros no
se trata de la distancia total recorrida
por el solvente sino la distancia
recorrida por el solvente desde este
origen desde donde pusimos el punto
justo aquí a partir del origen y
permíteme etiquetar esto como el origen
así que qué sucede en esta situación
bueno para ayudarnos a medir tenemos que
sacar una regla
entonces el factor de retención para la
sustancia justo aquí
todo este punto como a es igual a la
distancia recorrida por el soluto
podemos ver que viajó un centímetro un
centímetro
entre la distancia recorrida por el
solvente a partir del origen y vemos que
viajó 5 centímetros a partir del origen
entonces un centímetro entre 5
centímetros que es lo mismo que 0.2 y
luego el factor de retención de la
sustancia debe será igual a qué tan
lejos viejo bueno viajó 3 centímetros
del total de 5 centímetros del solvente
a partir de este origen más allá de
donde pusimos esta muestra 5 centímetros
lo que equivale a 0.6 así que fíjate que
en esta situación la sustancia más polar
tiene un factor de retención más bajo
que la sustancia menos polar y eso tiene
sentido porque la fase estacionaria es
más polar que el solvente por lo que las
cosas que son más polares son más
difíciles de mover por el solvente menos
polar